uh-oh
hi guys it's grace on location in alaska
and that's because today maybe heart and
i are debuting a brand new travel series
called hey usa and the first stop that
we
embark on is alaska and i'm going to
leave links to the trailers that dogs
here that dog loves alaska that's a
natural alaskan white dog i'll leave
links to the trailer or a brand new web
series all around here and today because
there's more men than women here
supposedly
so here are some alaskan pickup lines
that you can use
when you are in alaska
should i just stop here you just stand
here memory is going to be my um model
for this activity okay
ready here we go get out of bed for less
than five grand
i ship it
hey girl you don't have to date me
because i already want to tackle you
hey girl you give me porpoise
that's philosophical
don't be self-conscious girl i love a
girl with a puffin top
that's just rude no okay it's just a
natural animal that exists here
hey i know we're polar opposites but i'm
glad sure we could work
wait for us oh oh oh you know
hey girl do you want to have a lunch
because i'll ask a local for a really
good place
i use whaley twice
hey girl okay you're such a natural
beauty you make the tip of my iceberg
stiff
is your name titanic because i ship it
also you kind of look like a wreck
and there you go there are some alaska
pickup lines that you can use when
you're in alaska be sure to check out
the premiere episode or note the
premiere trailer for hey usa over on the
links down below and everywhere i don't
know
watch it
hey girl i'm really into social media i
rarely want to book
time and link
oh